[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 19 juin
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 60
18 26 minutes pour un condensé de
l'actualité locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition c'est l'événement de
l'aéronautique et du spatial le salon du
bourget se tient jusqu'à dimanche sur
place cette année des entreprises basées
dans le département dont une trentaine à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines étude inédite
lancée sur le territoire pendant trois
ans le collège va être analysée par
l'association de la plaine de versailles
initiatives pour mieux connaître les
abeilles est davantage les protégés 30%
de ces insectes meurent chaque année en
france et elles seront martinique en
novembre et décembre prochain 3
yvelinoise ont participé au raid et
alizée un défi multisports et solidaire
engagé dans la team darcis line elles
représenteront l'association le cancer
du sein parlons-en
et puis à présentation également à tout
à l'heure en plateau à de la nouvelle
amap us saint martin c'est à montigny le
bretonneux pour débuter des nouvelles de
magalie tabareau l'une des présidentes
des assises de versailles agressé lundi
par deux hommes à son domicile du nord
des yvelines est la victime de 54 ans
souffre d'une fracture du plancher
orbital opérée elle ne perdra pas son
oeil qui a été touchée probablement par
un tir de l bd est le mobile de cet acte
restent encore inconnues les gendarmes
sont toujours à la recherche des deux
suspects casqués au moment des faits le
53e salon international de
l'aéronautique et du spatial a ouvert
ses portes ce lundi c'est tout bourget
en seine saint denis
un événement qui rassemble les
entreprises du secteur parmi elle est d
entreprise basée à saint quentin en
yvelines et travaille notamment sur les
moteurs du futur patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas landré des taxis
volant à l'énergie électrique des avions
fonctionnant avec des moteurs hybrides
des innovations présentées sur ce salon
du bourget 2019 par l'équipementier
aéronautique français
le groupe safran des technologies en
évolution permanente
peut pas dire aujourd'hui que l'airbus
a320 que vous prenez pour aller en
vacances sera totalement électrique dans
dix ans certainement pas en revanche
pour des véhicules beaucoup plus petit
donc on entend beaucoup parler
la mobilité à la demande mais aussi des
avions comme hutter aux régionaux de
quelques dizaines de passagers
eh bien les technologies pour être prête
beaucoup plus vite
le projet du moteur électrique et
hybride est développée notamment par
safran tech basée à magny les hameaux
un centre de recherche du groupe
inauguré en 2015
alors on travaille effectivement sur
comment rendre un moteur plus
électriques pour les avions de transport
de passagers
ces technologies là permettent des gains
de carburant
mais aussi des gains
d'efficacité en opération des coups de
coude usage par l'électrification et
l'assistance électrique en fait du
moteur classique c'est l'incontournable
du salon du bourget le rafale l'avion de
combat de l'armée française omnirôle
développé par dassault aviation
un appareil composé de pièces fabriquées
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le cas de cette antenne l'usiné
par le groupe bauwen et sa filiale
jacques loupé cli en collaboration avec
thales ce sont des systèmes de détection
ce qu'on appelle de la guerre
électronique et donc ils permettent de
détecter des cibles
pour protéger en fait tu n'auras phares
et de systèmes da nous sommes en pleine
croissance
actuellement en l'espace de cinq ans
gwen a doublé et nous avons la même
perspective pour les 5-10 professionnels
au total près de 60 entreprises
aéronautiques sont implantés sur saint
quentin en yvelines pour quatorze mille
emplois dans le secteur 79 ans que le
général de gaulle a prononcé son célèbre
discours c'était sur les ondes de la bbc
l'appelait à l'époque à ne pas déposer
les armes face à l'allemagne nazie
hier ont commémoré cet appel du 18 juin
une cérémonie commune comme c'est le cas
depuis plusieurs années s'est tenue
entre coignières nos repas et le mesnil
saint denis s'était devant le monument
de la malle me donne l'initiative
présidée par l'ancien maire de
coignières ory pas eu depuis 1989
cette année les enfants ont été associés
au devoir de mémoire et les interviews
récoltés par océane bazire et michael et
demi d'euros je crois que c'est
important que les jeunes à plus forte
raison parce que les témoins
disparaissent les uns après les autres
et il est important d associer à ces
moments où on se souvient ensemble
puisque c'est la définition même d'une
commémoration et je pense que l'on leur
transmet alors je ne sais pas si on leur
transmet l'histoire mon leur transmet au
moins des émotions voilà une démarche
qui est mémorielle qui est utile pour
les jeunes générations de comprendre
l'appel général de gaulle son contexte
le fond de sa pensée sur tout voilà
l'appel à la résistance pour combattre
l'allemagne nazie donc sa part
évidemment d'une bonne démarche qu'il
faut continuer dans l'avenir
environnement elles sont un maillon
essentiel de la biodiversité et les
abeilles de la plaine de versailles font
l'objet d'une étude inédite afin de
mieux les préserver leur pollen va être
étudié pendant trois ans les précisions
avec ce sujet d'aurélie ronces deux
petits grains qui contiennent une grande
quantité d'informations ce pollen vient
tout juste d'être prélevés dans cette
ruche situé à plaisir
il prendra ensuite la direction de la
belgique pour être analysés les abeilles
allant à 3km allons donc possibilité dur
de ramener énormément de diversité
florale de diversité de pollen donc ce
qui nous permet aux mettant devant
chacune de nos ruches une trappe à plein
de savoir exactement
quels sont les fleurs qui sont mutinés
c'est la ferme de gally à saint cyr
l'école qui est à l'origine de cette
étude
suite à des analyses du pollen de ses
ruches des carences concernant la
nourriture des abeilles ont été mises en
évidence
l'association de la plaine de versailles
qui regroupe 70 agriculteurs a décidé de
lancer une action à grande échelle
ça concerne tout le monde a des
diversités c'est c'est notre notre
assurance-vie et les abeilles sont un
élément extrêmement important de la
biodiversité
on a souvent des projets qui sont à
l'échelle d'un apiculteur mais de
vouloir impliquer tout un territoire
avec les agriculteurs les habitants et
les communes ça je pense pas que ça se
fasse ailleurs 30% des abeilles meurent
chaque année en france
les causes de cette mortalité sont
multiples même si à plaisir elles sont
plutôt épargné cet apiculteur a choisi
de prendre part à ce projet afin de
pouvoir mettre en place un plan d'action
et lutter pour leur sauvegarde
c'est vraiment le premier prélèvement
que je réalise et je souhaite bien sûr
continuer à faire ce genre de choses
le plus longtemps possible puisque ça
permettra aussi bon de définir et de
caractériser notre biodiversité sur sur
la plaine vers fall pour l'instant
quatre ruches installées sur ce
territoire sont concernés par cette
étude qui s'étale sur 3 à lui est en ce
moment le risque d'allergie au pollen
est très présent les yvelines sont
placés d'ailleurs comme 25 autres
départements en alerte rouge pour les
pollens de graminées
vous voyez cette carte établie par le
réseau national de surveillance
aérobiologique
si vous êtes allergique le rnsa
préconise de se protéger au moins les
yeux lors de vos sorties d'éviter de
rouler en voiture les vitres baissées
en cas de symptômes prenez contact avec
votre médecin traitant
elle vient de voir le jour à montigny le
bretonneux avec une première
distribution le 6 juin dernier la map
saint martin à une trentaine de familles
adhérentes les distributions de paniers
ont lieu chaque jeudi face à l'église
qui porte le même nom et pour en parler
jean-paul morcillo bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes
l'un des fondateurs de cette amap est
également trésorier alors amap
association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne si tu démarres une
démarche alternative de consommation et
qui met directement en relation le
producteur et un groupe de consommateurs
comment ça marche concrètement une amap
ça marche par préfinancement part à des
contrats de préfinancement l'association
choisie des producteurs et ensuite on
fait un contrat d' est par exemple les
légumes ils nous disent je vais vous
proposer tel produit tel produit
bien sûr des produits de saison ni bio
et on s'engage en tant qu'olympien samda
jeu sur une année six 6 mois sur les
produits à préfinancer la récolte du
producteur vous lisiez à la base il ya
ce contrat et on vit au rythme des
productions saisonnière tout à fait ne
peut pas cherche savoir quels produits
on va voir l'avancée le producteur
arrivent en particulier pour les légumes
on peut avoir des carottes et des pommes
de terre des tomates heures ne s'est pas
la base après s'il ya des produits qu'on
aime pas on peut échanger avec notre
métier mais ce n'est pas comme certaines
plateformes sur internet où on peut
choisir le produit lasser
c'est carrément vraiment le produit de
saison que nous avons on est dans une
démarche militante vous dirais que c'est
une agriculture plus respectueuse de
l'environnement
le responsable aussi alors je dirais
solidaire on est solidaire avec dany
renauld main parce que nous nous
travaillons avec des producteurs bio
donc le bio c'est bon pour le sol
c'est bon pour l'environnement et la
biodiversité nous travaillons un circuit
locaux le producteur le plus loin et à
26 km de montigny le bretonneux
nous sommes solidaires également avec
les agriculteurs puisque nous prêts
finançant leurs productions et quoi
qu'il arrive des aléas météo comme ça
nous allons payer la même chose que nous
ayons 5 kg de kilos dans le panier de
légumes et ensuite nous sommes également
solidaires ça c'est un petit plus de
notre amap
nous avons décidé moyennant 1 euro par
semaine et je veux remercier tous les
amapiens qui ont accepté de jouer le jeu
nous arrivons à financer un panier pour
une personne une famille en difficulté
financière en particulier ça peut être
une famille monoparentale
une femme tout seuls avec des enfants
mais qui a du mal quelques fois bouclées
les fans allemands et nous participons à
cela pour l'instant nous avons une
famille et nous espérons à tour de rôle
avoir trop quatre familles et chaque
semaine qui viendraient chercher son
panier
non c'est un genre de démarche que l'on
voit beaucoup à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pourquoi
l'annoncé cet amas pas à montigny le
bretonneux
alors avec christine bouvet la
présidente nous sommes déjà ma pierre
depuis 2011 avec les près de chez vous
qui s'est écrit sur mon team et qui
abuse de le délocaliser sur lui en cours
et nous trouvions un peu juste qu'il n'y
ait pas de damas sans dire que sur lui
en cours y en a 4 par exemple il y avait
une vraie demande des habitants
le mentionnait déjà nous avions pas mal
dans ma pièce de montigny qui venait sur
lui en cours et donc réfléchissent à
bienne c'était tout quid avance on
savait qu'on allait avoir du monde
d'aider la première réunion on avait
déjà une vingtaine d'adhérents et pour
arriver à la seconde réunion à
l'assemblée constitutive à 32 et bien
non nous sommes à trente six adhérents
36 adhérents aujourd'hui votre
producteur local il vient de magny les
hameaux
pour les légumes mines et vous avez
d'autres acteurs que nous avons le pen
qui fournit par le fournil de villiers
le bâcle le miel par la ferme de bel air
à villiers le bâcle également les
fromages de chèvre c'est la ferme de la
noue à la celle les bordes les fruits
c'est la maison gaillard a osé lever le
roi et le poulet et eux c'est la ferme
desclaux abonnés parler des exemples de
damas je crois que c'est le cas
notamment à trappes les amapiens
participent également récolte est ce que
c'est le cas à saint martin alors saint
martin on a un principe chacun à piennes
doit donner une journée à chaque
producteur donc ça peut cette journée
peut-être pour visiter la ferme pour
participer à la récolte ou au nettoyage
et au nettoyage aussi parce que étant
bio
les agriculteurs par exemple désherbe à
la mène donc ils ont besoin de main
d'oeuvre si on peut dire et donc c'est
une journée de partage une journée de
fête parce qu'on fait un bon pique nique
en même temps sur le temps de midi
mais voilà on aide le producteur suivant
sa production en passionné journée avec
des livraisons le jeudi entre 19 et 20
heures à la salle qui à face à l'église
saint-martin combien quentin un panier
alors le panier de légumes ses 22 euros
d'accord après là les fruits rouges que
nous avons actuellement ses 15 euros et
nous avons une kg 250 de fruits alors
les frais rousset les fraises cas
ciselure et puis après à l'automne hiver
on aura les poires le miel c'est le le
pot de 500 grammes et à 7,50 et et le
kilo à 15 ces mois là
les 36 familles ce qu'il reste des
places où vous avez tant la capacité
maximale alors nous essayons de rester
dans une structure familiale conviviale
donc nous sommes donné l'objectif
d'arrêter à 15 40 adhérents
donc nous avons 36 nous avons déjà des
adhérents qui n'ont pas pu avoir de
produits cette année qui ont déjà
réservé leur cotisation pour l'année
prochaine donc vous voyez on arrive à 38
dont il reste très peu de passes pour
l'année prochaine j'en ai toutes les
informations sur le lien qui s'est
affichée en bas de l'écran merci jean
paul morcillo je rappelle vous êtes le
trésorier de la map saint-martin
également l'un des décès des
cofondateurs co fondateur de cet amas
pied à montigny le bretonneux
l'été approche à grands pas pour
certains cela signifie vacances pour
d'autres la période est propice pour
faire des stages chaque année la maison
de l'europe des yvelines envoie une
vingtaine de jeunes à l'étranger pour
une expérience professionnelle de trois
mois et des stages effectués dans le
cadre du programme erasmus plus pour
certifier cette participation et valider
les compétences acquises quinze jeunes
ont reçu leur europass mobilité
cérémonie à la mairie de saint germain
en laye retour d'expérience avec deux
d'entre eux c'est au micro de maths
finances de nos confrères de radio
sensations c'était très enrichissant
j'ai appris beaucoup de moi même
j'ai je suis quelqu'un qui sort pas
beaucoup et je me suis donné beaucoup de
moi-même pour sortir beaucoup pour voir
beaucoup de choses pour aller dans les
pubs pour voir la culture sur le point
personnel et on découvre un nouvel
environnement de nouvelles choses et
professionnellement j'ai acquis pas mal
de compétences que j'aurais pas pu
développer spécialement dans un autre
travail
donc voilà c'est
ça apporte vraiment beaucoup de choses
sur pas mal de points je pense c'est
mobilité et si vous êtes intéressé par
la perspective de faire un stage à
l'étranger contacter la maison de
l'europe des yvelines
une nouvelle école de commerce est en
train de voir le jour à guyancourt en
établissement dédié aux métiers du sport
le ms ce porte business school cherche à
former les futurs professionnels des
fédérations des clubs et aussi des
multinationales l'école organise
actuellement des portes ouvertes michael
et demi d'euros et mélanie poker du
salon murat le ms le sport et par tous
les élèves ne chausseront pas de
crampons mais étudieront le sport
business
l'école forme des étudiants jusqu'au
master en france on recense uniquement
trois écoles qui qui propose une filière
complète autour des métiers du sport
business
un b3 à sa sortie pourra devenir chargé
de communication marketing management
dans l'hospitalité dans le sponsoring
etc etc
et puis un m2 il pourra devenir tout de
suite directeur marketing dans dans les
métiers du sport business
situé à guyancourt le ms et en
partenariat avec ubs cul pour accéder
vous amphithéâtre est la bibliothèque
universitaire ainsi de 750 m² de locaux
pour accueillir les 150 étudiants visés
par la direction
je suis passionné par le sport
je voulais faire du commerce en même
temps donc les 2 c ces parfaites
lâchement première année infirmiers mais
bon peut-être qu'après j'ai peut-être
changer de voir c'est pas et avec toutes
les implications que j'ai eues ici ça
pourrait peut-être me faire changer
d'avis en tout cas deux professeurs
permanents seront accompagnés par des
consultants les cours débuteront le 1er
octobre prochain
coût d'une année à partir de 8000 euros
sport encore tous les voyants sont au
vert pour le futur centre du psg à
poissy le club de la capitale vient de
recevoir l'avis favorable des
commissaires enquêteurs
ils ont remis leurs conclusions
positives suite à l' enquête publique
qui s'est déroulée entre février et mars
dernières validations attendue celle du
préfet des yvelines
les premiers coups de pioche eux sont
prévues pour septembre dans ce complexe
de 74 hectares le paris saint-germain
accueillera ses sections football
handball et judo un centre
d'entraînement avec une quinzaine de
terrains et des hébergements une
livraison prévue en 2021
cette aventure mais le sport et
solidarité le cinquième raid des alizés
se tient du 26 novembre au 1er décembre
en martinique 75 équipes vont prendre le
départ pour défendre une association et
l'une d'elles est avec moi en plateau
c'est la team darcis la une qui nous
vient de plaisir et de bois d'arcy
bonsoir mesdames alors autour de la
table nous avons flore faille véronique
dubois et cathy disent haut et vous
allez représenter sur place
l'association le cancer du sein
parlons-en on en parle dans un instant
déjà pour présenter ce raid seraient des
alizés c'est un raid multisports est
quelque chose qui est important c'est un
raid 100 % féminin un raid 100 % flanc
nature
pour lequel on ne connaît pas à l'avancé
les épreuves mais surprise on apprend la
veille au soir les épreuves qui auront
lieu le lendemain
quel type de sport vous aurais tellement
de l'ensreg vtt du canoë et peut-être de
là qu'on s'oriente à sion alors il ya
différents niveaux de participation on
va dire autour de la table flore c'est
votre troisième participation véronique
votre deuxième participation et cathy
c'est votre première on va faire un
petit tour de table
on commencera par cette première
participation pour vous 4 qu'est ce qui
vous a donné envie de vous joindre à
cette aventure et main tout d'abord ce
qui m'a donné l'envi c'est leur retour
de leurs deuxièmes de leur deuxième raid
en fait où elles sont revenus
complètement
transpo fin pas transformer mais presque
en fait avec un partage des émotions
qu'ils ont vécu sur place et donc j'ai
45 ans et je voulais me lancer un défi
et en plus c'est pour la bonne cause
donc voilà tout est réuni voulait
roenick deuxième participation qu'est ce
qui vous a donné envie de vous relancer
dans une nouvelle participation
le fait de le refaire en ayant la
connaissance de ce qui va un peu se
passer donc un peu plus d'assurance
et puis le goût du challenge j'aime ça
sachant que l'homme avait embarqué pour
la première fois donc en 2017 pour
l'année mais 40 ans donc voilà pour un
challenge des 40 ans cette année ce sera
un challenge et 45 pour cathy mais il
faut leur troisième participation pour
vous vous êtes une habituée désormais
oui on peut dire ça
en fait les raids c'est très addictif
moi je compare souvent les raids à un
accouchement et à la préparation et les
neufs mois de préparation et
l'accouchement le jour du raid est chez
lui trois enfants donc bon je m'arrête
pas pour les raids pour autant donc un
angle sportif à l'ong aussi solidaire
sur place vous encourez pour
l'association le cancer du sein
parlons-en
une femme sur huit est concernée sera
concerné par la maladie durant sa vie
pourquoi vous avez choisi de défendre
cette association
elle renage parce qu'il ya une femme sur
huit
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui qui est concerné
par ce cancer et il ya une solution pour
justement limité
celui ci c'est le dépistage donc en fait
l'association a pour but de promouvoir
ce dépistage des plus jeune âge c'est
que la majorité des cas de cancer pour
être guéri si le dépistage est réalisé
exactement
publ de dépistage est précoce fut la
maladie fait guéri alors d'ailleurs pour
pouvoir mener à bien cette aventure pour
aider aussi cette association les
sponsors sont primordiaux est ce que
vous êtes encore à la recherche de
sponsors est ce que c'est bouclé de ce
côté là 4 on est en pleine recherche
on a la moitié du budget aujourd'hui
donc effectivement on est en pleine
recherche de sponsors donc tout tout
donner et nous rapproche un peu plus des
départs donnés sur un budget de combien
pour et nous faudrait idéalement 5000
euros encore leur parti donc le message
est passé pour les sponsors on peut
contacter est la team sur le lien qui
s'affiche qui va s'afficher maintenant
en bas de l'écran on peut vous aider de
quelle manière d'ailleurs ses sponsors
ce que c'est plutôt une aide financière
une aide matérielle qui est que l'on
doit vous apporter dans un premier temps
on a vraiment besoin d'une aide
financière pour d'aider à boucler le
budget pour partir et après l'aide
matérielle peut venir par la suite mais
on a vraiment besoin d'argent pourquoi
partir un mot sur le côté sportif trois
jours de compétition qu'est ce qui vous
attend sur place même si le programme
définitif n'est pas tout à fait connu
mais à quoi vous vous attendez sur place
des paysages merveilleux on imagine déjà
martinique
oui des paysages merveilleux après un
fait de bouts
un peu de dénivelé du canoë ça aussi
c'est quand même particulier ce que
c'est du canoë en mer donc ça c'est une
préparation bien particulière qu'on ne
peut pas avoir ici donc très peu et puis
beaucoup de fous rires aussi puisqu'on
est quand même c'est un raid assez
difficile donc il ya des équipes sont
beaucoup plus performante
voilà on pourra l'être mais notre
objectif à la ses deux filles et comment
ça se prépare du coup participé à
diverses courses tout au long de l'année
exactement sachant que la dernière
course qu'on a fait là c'était dimanche
dernier c'était l'acte iii yala
versailles et puis différents trail
pendant toute l'année en photo dans le
département hors département
principalement magot sport running qu'
on peut retrouver un reportage
d'ailleurs tv 78 étaient sur place au
château de versailles on vous souhaite
quoi pour cette aventure d'aller
jusqu'au bout de pouvoir atteindre aussi
l'objectif je vous est fixé sur le
budget mais on vous souhaite bon courage
et merci de votre présence
cathy et et véronique de la team darcis
lane elle sera engagée cet hymne dans le
5e raid des alizés et c'est pour
défendre à l'association le cancer du
sein parlons-en le raid des alizés je
rappelle que c'est du 26 novembre au 1er
décembre
en martinique on va tout de suite au
cinéma pour notre petit tour du mercredi
dans les salles du territoire ce soir à
direction le grenier à sel attrape la
programmation de la semaine au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
le vendredi 28 juin à 20h45 au cinéma le
grenier à sel
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
basile dauga nice c'est lamine sissoko
pour leur film meltem basique soko est
un track list qui a commencé un petit
peu sa carrière dans le cinéma dans la
vidéo par les ateliers de la ville de
trappes
maintenant il est dans un long métrage
son premier long métrage il avait déjà
tourné un court-métrage avec une base il
d'organismes et ils se sont retrouvés
pour ce long métrage est donc mais le
thème c'est l'histoire de trois jeunes
français qui partent en vacances on
était sur une île grecque et leurs
vacances sont un petit peu bouleversée
par la rencontre avec un réfugié syrien
dans cette île grecque
on suit leur histoire
à tous les trois tous les cartes
maintenant avec ces réfugiés et donc on
aura la chance d'avoir les trois acteurs
principaux et le réalisateur qui
viendront nous parler de ce film ce sera
vendredi 28 juin à 20h45 au cinéma le
grenier à sel pour trouver tout ça sur
cinéma grenier à sel points comme de
vence laisse pantois
16 francs peau mais sans racines là je
sais même pas où tu vas tu es là tu
crois que tu va sauver le monde
[Applaudissements]
coriace
[Musique]
non
et puis toujours attractifs fêtait ses
20 ans le cycle mythe s'est tenue tout
récemment à la salle de la merise quatre
établissements de saint quentin en
yvelines ont pris part à ce championnat
inter collèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale retour sur la soirée avec
mélanie poker ils sont donc les
vainqueurs de ce 20è massique mythe
il s'agit bien sûr de l'équipe de la
route
[Applaudissements]
le trophée last à coignières pour la
deuxième année consécutive la mare au
sol remporte le concours intercollèges
d'improvisation le match était super
cool
les six autres équipes étaient super
forte et on s'attendait pas du tout à
être en finale et les matches étaient
très serrés au on est resté dans le jeu
à fond et puis et puis c'est vraiment à
la fin l'effet de surprise on s'y
attendait pas forcément et on est super
heureux parce que bah c'est en bus c'est
la deuxième année du coup j'ai pas eu
grand chose à faire en vrai un mois je
m'asseyais dans une salle et je les
regardais jouer et ça suffisait
largement ils se sont tous très bons il
ya un très bon groupe mais ça reste très
important et là franchement ce soir je
pense que les quatre équipes étaient
hyper homogène ça a donné des très
belles rencontres
une victoire obtenue face à une coriace
équipe orr pas et n le collège alexandre
dumas s'incline 3 points à 4
comme c'est ma dernière année j'ai kiffé
j'aurais bas je remets ça dure plus
longtemps mais comme d'habitude bas
honnêtement j'ai bien aimé cette finale
franchement même les demi-finales des
touristes et sympathique qu'on soit 2e
4e ou quoi l'important c'est qu'on s'est
bien amusé de l'improvisation compter à
la création chanter les quatre collèges
en compétition dû rivaliser
d'imagination devant les thèmes imposés
j'étais bien avec mon chien je vais
chercher le fusil
le podium est complété par le collège
des prés à montigny le bretonneux cette
année 14 collèges sont affrontés tout au
long de l'année des rencontres pour
désigner un vainqueur qui vise la passe
de trois pour la prochaine édition et la
finale complet du cycle mythe est à
retrouver sur tv 78,7 était première
diffusion le mardi à 16 juillet ce sera
à 21h ou bien sur notre site internet tv
78 points com où vous pourrez également
consulter le replay de ce journal cette
édition touche à sa fin belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]